hey if you want to get some exclusive
anime merge and also directly support
this channel at the same time check out
our online store at anime Lord calm we
have original designs created by pro
manga artist Kazuma including this esken
or praise the Sun shirt and now
featuring a brand new design Mele
Otisfield a Rath link is in the
description you can use the discount
code uproar 25 for an instant 25% off at
checkout
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about one of the biggest
unsolved mysteries in the entire world
of the seven deadly sins the true race
and origin of Merlin the most mysterious
member of the seven deadly sins when the
story first begins we are told that all
seven sins come from different races and
clans we know that the N is a giant king
is a fairy s Kannur is a human bond is
formerly a human but becomes immortal
later meliodas is a demon Gotha is an
artificial creation and merlin well we
don't know about Merlin she is the only
one whose true race and background is
still a mystery but while doing research
for the dozens of seven deadly sins
videos that I've made here on the
channel I came across a bunch of
fascinating clues and theories about the
secret of Merlin's true race and origin
in this video I will be going over all
of the clues throughout the story about
Merlin's background and I will give you
my theory about what I think Merlin's
true race is I've actually been meaning
to make this video for quite a while and
I'm very excited to get into the dark
past and true identity of a character as
mysterious and interesting as Merlin if
you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
content on this channel you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell you can
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime up or for all the latest 7 Deadly
Sins updates and finally spoiler alert i
will have to go into all the information
from the manga about merlin to really do
a good job with this video so please
proceed with caution
let's start with what we do know about
merlin and her mysterious origins even
though she looks like a young woman
merlin is actually over 3,000 years old
and her true name is not merlin at all
she only uses this name because humans
cannot pronounce her true name the fact
that humans cannot pronounce her name
clearly implies that she herself is not
human but it's actually a bit more
complicated than that
merlin was born in beli Alwyn a city
once known as the cap
of the Wizards sometimes translated as
the capital of the sages but I will just
say Wizards from now on her birth was a
very unique and noteworthy event because
she was born with infinite magic aka the
magic ability called infinity because of
the incredible power of her magic the
warring goddess and demon clans both
tried to get Merlin to come over to
their side during the previous holy war
and they each offered secret magical
knowledge in return for her support but
rather than picking either side
Merlin trick to both the demon king and
the supreme deity into thinking that she
was making a deal with them in order to
receive the rare magical knowledge
offered by both sides so the demon king
gave her knowledge about the dark
secrets of the demon realm and made her
immune to the brainwashing and
possession techniques used by the
goddess clan the supreme deity gave her
the ability to protect herself against
the dark curses used by the demons the
rulers of the goddess and demon clans
were apparently so angry that Merlin
tricked them in order to gain knowledge
from both sides that they decided to
destroy the entire city of beli Alwyn
but Merlin managed to escape the
destruction and she became the only
known survivor from the capital of the
Wizards it is believed that this is why
Merlin is known as the boar sin of
gluttony she couldn't say no to one side
or the other she just couldn't get
enough secret magical knowledge so she
is a glutton for knowledge it is worth
noting that due to some confusion with
the translation many people believed
that Merlin was the daughter of the
demon king and the supreme deity
however in chapter 249 we learned that
Merlin can't be the daughter of the
demon king and the Supreme Being because
it was only after she was born and
rumors spread about her ability to use
infinite magic that the demon king and
the supreme deity took an interest in
her also in chapter 243 we briefly see
Merlin's real father who at the time was
the only man aside from le ODIs to enter
purgatory however a minute in the
outside world is equivalent to a year in
purgatory and when Merlin's father
returned from purgatory he was an old
decrepit man so unless all of this
information that we have is actually
false Merlin is not the daughter of the
King and the supreme deity other
important things that we know about
Merlin's mysterious past include the
fact that she was trained in the magical
arts by both her father and the original
goal thir former member of the ten
commandments and the creator of the doll
Gotha while he was training her the
original goal Thurs stated that Merlin
had potential beyond even his own
understanding which is a huge statement
knowing how powerful the original goal
there was another interesting fact that
we know about Merlin is that 3,000 years
ago she was very close to the original
Elizabeth the goddess Elizabeth and she
actually called her big sis on top of
that we know that Merlin has a true form
and in this true form a Merlin looks
like a small girl now the question is
why does Merlin look like this in her
original form is it simply because
Merlin was that young when she first
activated her magical ability called
infinity and she simply stopped aging
after that or is it because she is
actually a member of a race of people
that look this way kind of like the
fairies all look very childlike but we
know that unlike the fairies Merlin does
not appear to have wings in her true
form and if she was something as obvious
as a fairy then they probably would have
mentioned that also when we see the
flashback with Merlin's father he looks
like an adult man so again this might
imply that Merlin just stopped aging
early on in life because of infinity we
can reasonably assume that Merlin is
neither of pure goddess nor a pure demon
because neither the demon king nor the
supreme deity knew about her until they
heard rumors about her power we can also
assume that she is not entirely human
because humans are not capable of
pronouncing her true name so if Merlin
is not a fairy
not a giant not a demon not a goddess
and not a human could she actually be
part of some completely different and
unknown race the seven deadly sins story
draws heavily from Arthurian legend and
the mythology of the British Isles and
besides fairies there are other
creatures which appeared childlike as
Merlin does in her truthful
including Pixies and Spriggans Pixies in
particular are interesting because
unlike fairies Pixies are often depicted
without wings and Pixies are thought to
be more closely connected to humans than
to magical creatures like the fairies in
fact back in the 1800s some scholars and
historians believe that Pixies were a
real race of smaller humans rather than
fictional creatures this human
connection is important because of what
we learned in the new seven that Lee
sends prisoners of the sky movie when
Sol add the celestial asks all the sins
except for meliodas who is not present
at the time if they are demons
Merlin clearly states that none of them
are members of the demon clan
she says that s canora's human bond is a
former human and she is and I quote well
something like that so she tells us that
she is not a demon and that she is
something like a human but then she
doesn't give us any more information
after that now I realized that some
people considered a movie to be
completely separate from the main story
because of the inconsistent timeline but
I have to emphasize that the timeline
being off doesn't mean that the
information we got in the movie about
the world and characters of the seven
deadly sins is completely false
in fact the official mangaka NACA Basu
Sookie really went out of his way to
connect the information in the movie to
the main storyline not only were the new
characters in the movie created by the
original manga cop but in Chapter two or
three of the official seven deadly sins
manga the six nights of black were
actually mentioned the inderal
retribution that appears near the end of
prisoners of the sky was also introduced
in the manga the name of this Endora is
Baraka and he was said to be an
acquaintance of gallant on top of that
chapter 277 of the official manga
features so lot and a lot a two
characters from the movie right on the
cover in the movie we also learned the
identity of their mother of chaos and as
a bunch of you wonderful space cowboys
pointed out in my video about the
prisoners of the sky movie including
Gogeta ancien moon vegeto the way
sword that we see in the movie is
actually shown in chapter 274 of the
manga in a flashback we see a young male
wielding what appears to be that very
same sword so with all of these
connections to the main storyline I
think that we would have to be crazy to
just dismiss all of this to information
that the movie gives us about the world
of the seven deadly sins and if we
accept that Merlin is not a demon or
even half-demon as she says in the movie
and as is implied by the fact that she
was born in the capital of the Wizards
rather than in the demon realm or the
celestial realm then we know that she is
something like a human but still not
quite human after all
regular humans can't pronounce her true
name even though they have no problem
pronouncing the names of demons
goddesses fairies Giants or any other
type of creature in order to get to the
bottom of what Merlin's true race is we
have to look at the place of her birth
belly allowin the capital of the Wizards
which was destroyed more than three
thousand years ago by the demon king and
the supreme deity the name belly allowin
most likely comes from the word belly au
which was used to refer to the devil in
Jewish and Christian religious texts
Merlin is called the daughter of belly
allowin and when certain characters hear
this phrase including powerful
Commandments like gray road and fraud
Rijn they appear to be clearly
intimidated by Merlin now sons of Belial
or daughters of Belial is a term that
was used in biblical times to refer to
lawless men basically men and women who
live outside the boundaries of the law
so outlaws criminals people who reject
conventional society and so on this term
had a clearly negative connotation these
were people who rejected the things that
we considered to be valuable for society
such as rules and laws these sons of
Belial are basically considered to be
criminals and sinners so what if this
word Balliol which is the root of belly
allowin is actually a hint about the
wizards and their true origins assuming
that merlin is telling the truth when
she says that she is something like a
human what exactly could this mean
we know that in the world of the seven
deadly sins not all humans are the same
for instance the Druids are human but
they are a unique group of humans that
live in isolation from other humans deep
inside the forest
the Druids look like normal humans
although many of them tend to have
silver hair or white hair and the Druids
worship the goddess clan and they
consider the demon clan to be their
natural enemy
unlike most ordinary humans the Druids
are much more in touch with nature with
animals and with the spirit world and as
a result they are able to perform
magical spells and techniques that
normal humans cannot these spells
include the ability to heal as well as
the power to destroy dark and corrupt
souls such as the souls of demons which
are all techniques that they share with
the goddess clan it is believed that
these techniques were taught to the
druids by the goddesses as a reward for
their devotion now in order to perform
these spells the Druids are able to use
secret incantations that other humans
cannot understand and that is somewhat
similar to the fact that Merlin's true
name cannot be pronounced or understood
by humans the fact that Merlin's true
name cannot be pronounced by humans and
the fact that she still describes
herself as something like a human seem
contradictory at first but if the
Wizards from beli allowin were a unique
group of humans like the druids of
Ishtar perhaps humans who acquired
certain special magical abilities that
made them different from normal humans
then all of this starts to make a lot
more sense what if the Wizards from
Valhalla wind were humans who violated
the laws of nature by experimenting with
magic until they learned forbidden
spells and became something different
than just normal humans perhaps just
like the Druids worship the goddess clan
and were rewarded in returned with
magical knowledge by the goddesses the
Wizards worshiped another clan perhaps
the demon clan and were rewarded by the
demons with demonic magical knowledge
this would explain how the original goal
thir who was apparently a demon just
happened to be the person who trained
Merlin maybe like the Pixies in British
mythology the Wizards were originally
human but their use of forbidden magic
and isolation from other humans made
them into a
group a group that is something like
humans but not quite what we think of
when we think of ordinary humans if this
were true it would also explain the use
of the word belle-isle for the capital
of the Wizards belly allowin because the
term sons of Belial
or daughters of Belial was used to refer
to lawless men and women ie criminals
and sinners it makes sense that the
Wizards would inherit this name if as I
predict they were experimenting with
forbidden magic and committing acts that
were considered taboo by the other
humans we already saw that humans who
consume demon blood and experiment with
it can actually use it to become more
powerful as the new generation of holy
Knights did so perhaps the Wizards did
something similar
perhaps they experimented with demon
blood and other forbidden substances in
order to make themselves far more
powerful than ordinary humans in some
accounts of the legend of King Arthur
Merlin is said to have been born to a
human mother and a demon father and
while it's obvious that we can't apply
Arthurian legend to strictly in relation
to the seven deadly sins because in the
legend Merlin is a man not a woman the
idea that the Wizards were perhaps using
demonic magic or demon blood to become
more powerful and as a result
Merlin ends up being born with infinite
magic could be a very interesting homage
to the Merlin from Arthurian legend so
is this the dark secret of Merlin's true
race and mysterious origins she is a
member of the Wizards a unique group of
humans who became more powerful by
violating the laws of nature and
experimenting with forbidden magic which
eventually made them more than just
human they were still something like
human but not quite the same thing you
may think that if this were the case we
would have heard more about these
wizards especially since we do know
quite a bit about the Druids however if
we take into consideration that the
capital of the Wizards was destroyed by
the demon king and the supreme deity
over 3,000 years ago and Merlin is
believed to be the only survivor then of
course we wouldn't know much about them
the Wizards have been practically
extinct for more years than almost
anyone still alive can even remember
excluding of course Mellie Otis and some
of the demons and goddesses and Merlin
herself is extremely secretive
and mysterious so it makes perfect sense
that we know next to nothing about the
Wizards however I predict that we will
learn more about them as the story
progresses and personally I can't wait
to find out the truth behind Merlin's
origins and her incredible magic
infinity well let me know what you guys
think do you agree with my theory about
Merlin and the Wizards or do you have a
different theory of your own about
Merlin's true race feel free to give me
your thoughts down in the comments
without having all the necessary
information we have no choice but to
speculate so if you have a different
theory no hard feelings go right ahead I
mean I don't know maybe the answer is as
simple as when Merlin's father went into
purgatory he ended up meeting the mother
of chaos they had a great time together
and Merlin was the end result
this would make Merlin half human half
creature from purgatory and it would
also explain her tattoo whatever your
theory might be if you enjoyed this
video you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve for more 7 Deadly
Sins content don't forget to follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime up
lore for all the latest seven deadly
sins updates as always thank you all so
much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you